game i finished winning that madden game
i run into this dorm room
and i hear the following thing my friend
is sitting in front of this
thing and he clicks some buttons and i
hear
kuch remember that [ __ ] remember paying
13 [ __ ] dollars a minute to be on the
internet [ __ ] aol
anyway it's another story
so i hear this thing right we were
getting
do you guys remember that bill i mean
there's some youngsters in this crowd
you guys don't remember we were getting
killed out there
my friend signs in he goes into this
chat room
he types in a slash s slash
l another classic
and he looks at me because he's sitting
and i'm up here i'll never forget this
look
for the rest of my life he looks at me
and he goes we can get
chicks on this thing
and as long as i let the pause just
happen now while you were laughing
because that made me feel really good by
the way thank you
was about as long as i paused before my
brain said
i can sell [ __ ] on this thing and that
was it my life changed again
right there and there i waited like
seven hours after every person sat